all right damian
yes sir damian so nice to see you this
morning good thing you just
saw you strolling by with your your
shopping cart full of recycling
stuff yeah and you told me some very
interesting news
yeah i uh i'm uh going on four months
clean now
so you kicked fentanyl yep and heroin
too
yeah oh i got the uh great help of these
though
i gotta put these out just to let the
world know that
these are available to them free
all day you know
and they help tremendously what are
these
suboxone oh yeah
well i guess i it's oh so you you are
using suboxone yeah yeah
i kicked cold turkey for it to resonate
and stick with me
you know the horribleness of it yeah but
then afterwards
because i i have all these prosthetic
parts
i uh took that just for a pain reliever
you know
and also it uh acts as a um
almost like an inhibitor you know from
me doing more dope because
if i was to do dope like fentanyl or
heroin it just
wouldn't get me high at all okay so i
thought when you told me you went cold
turkey i just figured you went cold
turkey and quit and that was it but
using suboxone which which i guess is
very helpful right yeah
yeah a lot of times i use the suboxone
for my prosthetic knee metal hand metal
jaw
metal eye socket back problems and stuff
how does it feel to be clean from
fentanyl
good yeah i i noticed i got uh quite
a lot of time on my hands now that i'm
not doing the uh
24 7 uh dope search you know
right like you know i don't have to
hustle for dope money
i don't have to go and find the dope man
once i get the dope money
you know and that that uh consumed uh
pretty much how many years were you
using um
all together uh like 25 years
25 years and how old do you know 43 43
and what so what's you've been clean
four months
yeah it's a lot that's enough time to
like be able to look
back at that period of your life what
are your thoughts on
on that period of addiction
um just didn't
i don't enjoy looking back on it you
know because i mean
it's like all the stuff that i did you
know to get it
i mean i wouldn't i wouldn't do what
other people do
you know sell themselves and i don't
steal
but i mean i dig through trash cans for
recycling or i was
panhandling you know holding a sign
and that that in of itself is horrible
because i mean you get these people
driving by just cursing you out
telling you get a job and they got all
these uh
great uh smart ass uh ways of like
as if you don't have enough shame
already yeah stalking it to you you know
they're like oh hey come here bro i got
something for you hungry
i'm like yeah they're like come here
hurry up bro the light's gonna change
i'll go hobble over and they're like
here you go bro
don't spend it all in one place give me
two pennies
i'm like i guess it's better than
nothing
thank you and they're like all haha like
you know they just had the greatest
laugh of their life you know for uh
totally disgracing somebody and
making them feel like crap you know i
think i think
this little world this addiction world
is very misunderstood
by a lot of people yeah so where are you
staying now
uh in a tent you're in a town yeah but
you're not using you're surrounded by
drug addicts
yeah everywhere suboxone is uh what are
the ups and downs of suboxone
um the ups uh
it helps keep me off of dope
you know because i know that it's not
going to have any effect
if i wanted to do dope i'd have to stay
clean off of it for at least
five days you know and by then the uh
the itch would be way gone
but then i'm gonna slowly start weaning
myself off you know
cause i'm not planning on staying on
that you know for an extended period of
time that's legal
yeah could you if you wanted to
get a get a full-time job and
if i got somebody yeah
yeah it's a
um it's a classified as a narcotic
but um i would think uh
well i don't know actually i'm i'm not
really sure
you know i mean i i hear that people uh
have and they do work on it
but um truthfully i'm not 100 sure
you know because i mean it says you know
don't operate heavy machinery no but if
you if you needed to get a job at a
grocery store or something like that you
could do that oh yeah
yeah is that in the cards for you you
think uh once i get my id
but uh that's not so much in the cards
as in me
getting my own business started with a
sober living home
oh really so tell me what you want to do
uh well i'm
waiting to get my stimulus so that i can
travel to arizona
where i used to stay for a little bit
and
i gonna cash out all my 401ks out there
through macy's dillards uh
texaco chevron make model near
shasta pools white water pools
um a couple other places
and then start a sober living thing to
help others yeah
good for you and then i'd like to expand
too you know to
to a rehab if i could you know but that
is going to take me a little bit of time
i i researched it and
i have to attend school to get a
uh to be certified to be a substance
abuse
counselor and then from there then i
could uh
open up a rehab good for you yeah
i figured i'd have the like edge on
helping people
seeing as how i've been through it all i
think you can help others and that [ __ ]
it would help your
your whole the way you view yourself by
helping
other people i mean i'm slowly like
viewing myself a little bit better than
i was you know like i can sense that
thank you when you first walked up i'm
like wow that's damian
i mean tremendously lost weight but i
mean i'll get that back
you're always lean anyway yeah but no
you i can see it in your face and the
way you speak and your eyes and
everything you seem a little
clearer and healthier yeah i mean i feel
i feel a lot better tell me about uh
what it's like to go cold turkey off of
heroin or oh fentanyl ooh
horrible i mean uh it's like worse than
uh
heroin and longer too you know
and first off what's the difference
between uh heroin and fentanyl you've
done both right yeah
uh as far as in the high no it's yeah i
guess the high and the and
and the addiction and then the
withdrawals okay um well the high
heroin was uh
heroin is not as strong
but when i initially started it
[Music]
it hit me pretty
pretty good but with me my chemistry is
like a little mixed up
so i would get hyper
for the most part and when i do heroin
i'd be out and about you know just
all over the place and uh
just to put it into perspective when i
was doing a speed
methamphetamines uh i get tired
and i can go to sleep yeah i think i
think all these drugs affect each person
differently yeah
for most people i think meth keeps some
up right yeah
and but like i've been running into
people though
such as myself that uh it gets them uh
like tired you know because uh our
chemistry i think
because i'm adhd yeah i think that's got
a lot to do with it yeah
and uh then fentanyl when fentanyl hit
the
the stage um yeah wow it was a
it was a different world you know i was
i didn't have to shoot up and i could
take like one or two hits of this stuff
you know when i first started mind you
and
i'd be lit you know like
i i would be like at first i'd be like
just comatose you know
like i would normally be off a heroine
but
then uh once my body got uh
i guess acclimated to it all i started
to get uh
the energy and hyper off of it too you
know
like i'd see people and it frustrated me
because i'd see somebody
i'd smoke with them you know i'd give
them one hit
next thing i know i'm having to give
them narcan i'm having to breathe for
them
because they're dying in front of me
yeah
very dangerous and um
[Music]
and so i'm like okay i revive them and
i'm like thinking
cool you know this is going to get me
high as hell too
one hit just put this dude out and he
does as much as i do you know i'd take
like 30 or 40 hits
and get nowhere near what that person
got you know and i'm like
it was kind of frustrating you know yeah
because i i mean
my body it's a it's something else um
i i to i mean to say the very least it's
very strong
because i mean it's gotten me this far
so far you know and uh i mean
blessed but um
it uh it
uses uh substances differently you know
like once i
once i uh initially do it
after that first time it's like body's
like already saying like all right
you're gonna have to up the dose you're
gonna have to do a heck of a lot more
get some stronger [ __ ] you know with
fentanyl yeah
that's that's incredible yeah i've never
heard that yeah i'd be using uh
like just a lot you know in comparison
to everybody else you know
and so tell me about going cold turkey
oh yeah
so i did cold turkey on the heroin that
was horrible
uh stomach you know upset
diarrhea throwing up cold sweats
fentanyl is pretty much the same only
more intense and how long this is
uh it took me like two three weeks
like solid two or three weeks you know
of like just
feeling like like [ __ ] you know
i've heard it described by a lot of
heroin or fentanyl addicts that
like dying is preferable yeah
like i would i would i would hope like i
was sitting there
and i would like be saying out loud you
know why can't you just kill me god you
know i don't want to be alive you know
and i was meaning every bit of it too
because i mean
when every single cell in your body is
screaming out
in pain and just saying stop this you
know
and i mean wow it's something else
and then all the previous pain that i
have normally
gets magnified like a hundred fold you
know
so it's like i i could get like a paper
cut and just
i mean if i was dope sick and you know
i'd be on the ground balling pretty much
you know
like oh this paper cut's killing me
you know and it would like feel it would
really feel like uh
it was that horrible you know
[Music]
so um quite a quite a doozy though quite
a ride i'll tell you
well i'm excited that you're uh you're
considering a sober living or a rehab
thing
for others i mean it's a
something that i i think is going to
help me
to stick with the uh the proper path
you know i can totally see you doing
something great with your life thank you
of all the people i've interviewed like
you're one of the handful that i really
see like he has potential to do
something great i appreciate that very
much
stuff like that you know really helps
helps out a person's uh
psyche you know especially when they're
going through the
getting sober apart you know because i
mean i'm still
i consider myself still a guppy yeah
four months is nothing really yeah no
i i did a heroine once
like quit cold turkey and i uh stayed
off of that for almost nine years
nine years yeah well eight a little over
eight years that's what that's great
yeah so you're capable of doing great
things in your life you just have to
find a stick with it and get away from
this neighborhood yeah well
kind of i kind of want to stick around
so i could help a lot of the people
though
you know but i don't want to stick
around you know like too much
just like be around you could be like a
you know
a mile or two off the yeah part of skid
row and probably still get your job done
yeah and i'm still waiting for uh
housing
i mean there have been people that i
got set up with the housing people
and they were set up like two three
months after me
and they've been in an sro like almost a
year now
yeah and i'm still sleeping on the
streets and i'm like
how does that work i i got you signed up
months
after me the whole world is upside down
right yeah and you're in an sro and i'm
not
and i'm trying to do something with my
life and you're definitely not
you know it's like do they like have
like a
like a prerequisite like you have to
like
follow like to get housing all right you
got to be a dope fiend
you got to be a scumbag thieving piece
of [ __ ]
you know and uh yeah just be a horrible
person
and we'll get you a place you know but
oh you're trying to do something with
your life
nah you can you can sit out there and
you know wilt away like the rest of the
the flowers out there you know
it's like [ __ ] well you'd be a rarity i
think i think
there's not a lot of people that have
done what you're trying to do yeah
so they're maybe from their perspective
you're just like nuts
so tell me about recycling how much how
much will you
get for that probably like 10 or 15
bucks and then you use that for what
food food that's your whole existence
basically right now
and that uh 10 and 15 bucks took me uh
all day yesterday and then all last
night
and then uh this morning you walked down
the right the right block today then
yeah definitely
i'm so stoked to see because i wouldn't
have done it
if this place this recycling place right
yeah i don't know why they're close i
know that here's the thing they
i'm blessed though right now that they
don't know how to operate
properly you know because uh like every
day they're supposed to be open at 8 30.
and uh yesterday they didn't open until
9 30
you know and we're all standing out
front like you know what's going on
they're inside just like
dinking around doing nothing you know
it's like can we like uh
cause i'm starving you know uh what's up
oh give us a minute we have to get
everything ready
you mean get everything ready you know
y'all don't have to get nothing ready
you have some empty trash cans that we
go in
and we put our stuff into and then you
take the stuff we put in
and you dump it in a big container
so what the do you have to get ready you
know
but does does living this life where
you're you're going through garbage cans
to find
plastic bottles and cans and stuff like
that and living on the street and
this whole lifestyle is is it so it just
makes you feel bad about yourself and
you're
for a little bit yeah but at the same
time i try and
i've been trying to think on a more
positive level that um
i'm doing what everybody else out there
isn't i'm recycling i'm helping the the
planet
you know and i try and think about that
so much you know but
then you get somebody who comes along
and while i'm digging through the trash
they'll throw their trash at me you know
and then start laughing about it you
know and i'm like wow you could have at
least said excuse me
or something you know you didn't have to
throw it right at me you know what just
i would just plow through this period of
your life
get out of here use it to make yours
make yourself stronger yeah i think i
think you'll learn a lot about
human nature and the way that people
function and operate a lot a lot of it
isn't uh
isn't quite an acquired taste though to
learn you know because it's like
i don't understand why a lot of people
do some of the horrible things that they
do
it's a cruel world it's a cruel world
but it's also a beautiful world at the
same time
that it's both yeah i think you have to
hang on the book i think the human
factor
makes it a cruel and ugly world
you know yeah but humans can also be the
most inspiring and beautiful things
you've ever seen yeah both yeah and we
can be the most disappointing and cruel
beings ever the sad part is though
to me it seems like the good people
the people that inspire the people that
help and and
give love to others you know they're
they're decreasing in numbers you know
well you're in the wrong
part of the world right now i'm in
self-centered l.a
well no i would say just this downtown
skid row area is probably
oh yeah yeah you're surrounded by snakes
and
vultures okay so you're not gonna find a
whole lot of
yeah they're thinking i'm a carcass
waiting to be picked clean you know
yeah yeah no and the fact that you're
not using makes you maybe a little
clearer
more clear-headed so you know you're
seeing the reality of what's what you're
in
and i'm not getting taken advantage of
as as easily
because before it would be like i'd be
up for a couple days you know
and then i'd smoke some fentanyl and i'd
be out
just out cold and people would come and
friends my supposed friends though and
they'd dig through my pockets
empty out my pockets while i was asleep
and normally
you know if uh like a fly flew by me
you know this is me on a sober level fly
goes by me i'm waking up like
[ __ ] was that you know but i mean when i
was on that stuff you know
people are all dude to do hey you want
to give me a hand you know
let's take his pants off too while we're
at it [ __ ]
what's the most horrific thing you've
experienced
when you're living on the street as an
addict oh
getting robbed right across the street
while two police officers watched
had a gun to my head another guy had a
knife in my back
and they stripped me down to my i had
sweats on and a pair of shorts they took
the sweats
it was nighttime winter they took my
sweaters and stuff i was left in my
tank top my shorts and no shoes or socks
and they took all my money my phone
everything
and all my clothes and stuff backpack
everything
while the cops stood right across the
street and watched
and then when all that was done i i
walked across the street and i'm like
what the [ __ ] you know they're like what
do you mean what the [ __ ]
i was like you guys stood there and
watched me get
robbed for everything and you stood
there and watched
they're like oh they're robbing you oh
we figured it was just friends [ __ ]
with you i'm like
okay did you not see the gun you know to
the side of my head
you know you obviously couldn't see the
knife in my back you know but i mean
really you know what the [ __ ] are you
all here for i mean
you know what what good are you doing
you know if you're not helping somebody
who's getting robbed right in front of
you
you know they're like they make a joke
about it like oh what let me guess
how much you get robbed for a million
dollars
[Music]
and i'm like no it was like 64 bucks
and my phone and everything that i need
to survive
you know wasn't a million dollars but on
that note
not funny you know i was like not
[ __ ] funny at all
you know and as i'm sitting there
telling them that they uh
are they're turning around and they're
walking away from me
you know like just cold shoulder it's
skid row
yeah this is right in front of macy's
actually oh downtown yeah
they were posted up right in front of
macy's and i was directly across the
street
all right damian well great seeing you
again yeah you too really
pleased to see your situation is
improving yeah really proud of you
thank you very much i hope it all kinds
of great things come your way
yeah me too and you as well you know
because i mean you help out a lot of
people you know and
i mean i just wanted to say no i don't
know i'm an exploited bastard racist
yeah you're none of that you know you're
if it depends on which comment you read
on my channel
oh is it oh yeah yeah you're a genuinely
nice guy
racist my ass you know i mean you have
like every
kind of person that's working for you
helping you you know it's like
i think social media is just a circus of
yeah
whatever they can try and develop a
thick skin yeah
it's kind of like being in skid row you
develop a thick skin yeah
but i don't want it to get too thick to
where i just you know
i turn out like a lot of them out there
you know just
someone says hi how are you and you're
just like no i don't see that happening
to you
yeah i can see great things to you man i
think
cardio all right i'm keeping it up you
know excellent
great job
appreciate that very much you know oh
dude you're inspiring thank you
god bless you're you're inspiring you
help me out you know
mentally like big time you know the
stories
that i get down here